bonjour david inhalent bonjour monsieur
vu le temps bonjour à toute l'équipe de
la matinale et surtout toute la
martinique en particulier le sud
candidat d' ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle dans la circonscription du sud
à dire vrai david inhalent votre
candidature surprend parle même de vous
ce n'est pas très élégant jeu de boules
à cordes de candidature par défaut cela
vous l'avez entendu non je n'ai pas
attendu
je sais simplement que beaucoup de
personnes m'approche me téléphone pour
me dire original vous emmener de la
fraîcheur et du nouveau dans cette
campagne
alors je veux faire le maximum pour être
à la hauteur de cette attente de la
population qui cherchent de la fraîcheur
et la nouveauté il n'y avait pas de
pléthore ya pléthore de candidats arnaud
rené-corail des trois îles est douchée
par son expérience précédente
nicaise monrose merde c'est plus pas
très volontaire soutiennent ah oui ils
ne soutiennent plus cléments sollicités
ils m'ont aidé jusqu'à maintenant je
suis toujours avec eux en discute
puisque nous sommes tous du sud et nous
voulons développer le sud et faire le
maximum pour que le site réussissent
demain vous y avez c'est d'abord une
question de volonté personnelle quelque
chose que vous avez longuement préparée
oui j'ai très personnel et en plus je
veux pas dire qu'on a réquisitionné ni
non plus qu'on m'a poussé ces
volontaires j'ai fait ma demande auprès
du parti j'ai je suis allé voir les
partenaires ils m'ont sollicité donc
c'est un acte volontaire moi je pense
qu'en politique il est important qu'un
acte soit volontaire pour définitivement
la candidature par défaut on arrête avec
ça c'est évolue la politique aussi
puisque vous l'avez commencé depuis vos
amies étudiantes c'était à montpellier
dans les années 80 avec l'association
générale des étudiants martinique n est
pas qu il était question des libérations
nationales des luttes anticolonialistes
discours toujours d'actualité selon vous
oui aujourd'hui les choses en avant
c'est parce que dans le temps c'était
toutes les luttes en afrique en amérique
latine les luttes contre les dictatures
de l'amérique latine
et puis bien sûr les choses ont avancé
maintenant les luthiers pour protéger
migrants mais il ya toujours des luttes
à mener sur le front social sur le fond
politique et bien sûr sur le fond de
l'environnement parce que oui et
qu'aujourd'hui
l'environnement est menacé par tous par
la chine par des gens qui vont en
afrique dans le golfe du du niger tout
ça donc voilà là et sargasses viennent
ici mais viennent aussi d'ailleurs à
cause de l'environnement donc
aujourd'hui il y à une lutte importante
pour préserver la planète aussi le début
du militantisme pour david inhalent
c'était au sein de votre commune des
anses d'arlet vous êtes originaire de
là-bas vous êtes l'un des créateurs de
l'alliance arlésiennes et vous siégez
depuis 2014 au sein du conseil municipal
arlésien expérience suffisante pour
pouvoir prétendre à une députation
alors pour moi l'expérience la plus
importante est le long parcours depuis
18 20 ans dans la vie associative dans
la vie civile rappelle qu est
cardiologue
oui le médecin cardiologue et médecin du
sport et ce travail dès ma vie
d'étudiant à travers la culture le sport
est ici en martinique à travers
l'éducation à la santé les parcs ou
santé tout ce qui est les
infrastructures les produits anti crise
à falleron part qu il ce parcours est
encore plus prendre plus de temps que la
vie politique la vie politique a un
temps pendant les campagnes mais la vie
associative de tout ce qui est
prévention c'est du 1er janvier au 31
décembre il faut aller chercher des
fonds site pas évident il faut faire des
couloirs dans l'entente dans les
assemblées à la sécu partout je peux
vous dire vraiment il faut prendre son
bâton de pèlerin et donc je pense que
c'est très important et ça m'a vraiment
donné la france le jeu peut que j'ai
aujourd'hui et que je veux mettre cette
fraîcheur et cette fraîcheur que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure oui si cette
fois au regard sur la société par
exemple sur des thèmes majeurs comme ab
le mieux-être le bien-être la bonne
forme la santé la santé oui là c'est un
succès important parce que des points ou
même pour l'économie a besoin de la
santé pour que les gens puissent
travailler dans les bonnes conditions et
j'ai un petit moins g1
petite pensée pour une grosse pensée
même pour les tpe pour les artisans
poule et surtout les professions
indépendantes qui aujourd'hui sont les
oubliés de la protection sociale et les
oublier aussi de tout ce qui est santé
pourquoi parce qu'ils travaillent dans
l'entreprise mais je pense que ça aussi
ça m'a poussé à aller vers l'allée
l'aller les législatives parce qu'ils
ont besoin de soutien pour faire marcher
l'économie alors sport santé ce sont des
thèmes ça ne vous a pas échappé david
inhalent chère au député sortant jean
fini leur ancien sportif qui préside
également par exemple de l'institut
martiniquais du sport vous allez
discuter avec lui vous allez amener des
arguments face à lui sur ces thèmes
mais bien sûr puisque mois avec des amis
nous avons mis en place le centre
d'évaluation sur santé nous avons créé
le compas la coupe de l'amitié more
thing promotion des activités seront
santé nous sommes sortis du sport de
compétition pour aller vers le sport
pour tous notamment à travers les les
parcours santé les parcours du coeur et
l'éducation à la santé
donc aujourd'hui le terrain vous
connaissez how is a vraiment si un
terrain que je connais et que j'ai
appris avec des amis il faut différer
mieux pour la martinique pour les
martiniquais c'est ce que voulait faire
ah oui c'est important parce que au
niveau du gouvernement on parle à la
télé tous les jours vous en particulier
et je vois des médias manger bouger mais
il faut apprendre à manger
donc il faut savoir avec quels acteurs
comment faire ensuite bouger mais il va
de dire aux gens de bouger si vous
n'avez pas trop des infrastructures la
basse baryton si vous pouvez pas marcher
le long des routes pascal martinez n'y a
pas de bas côté il ya de l'herbe
il n'y a pas d' espaces boisés vous les
enfants donc séparé du maire ça suffit
non mais c'est un programme général ce
sens et si le retard des infrastructures
c'est fondamental et ça va dans le sas
et la soumettrai la faune sont entre
autres michel y aller on parle
d'illégalité et là je vois quand je
marque parti à parler de discrimination
ils vont encore plus loin donc de cette
discrimination intéresse tous les pans
de la société
ces inégalités donc il nous faut aller
chercher ça et je pense que haut
depuis la loi égalité grille et 7 ans
sera discussions en retour à l'assemblée
après après après le sénat il y à de
très belles avancées mais maintenant il
faut effectivement concrétisé et dans la
mandature qui va venir il faut mettre en
application donc les députés qui vont
être élus ou à se battre pour qu'on
attende pas encore 20 ans parce que ça
fait quand même 70 ans que césaire est
monté à l'assemblée à 46 vous voyez
comment votre rôle de député alors bien
sûr le rôle du député c'est d'abord
travaillé à travers les lois et il sera
par contre il ya un travail important à
faire en commission en présence dans les
commissions faut il compter les groupes
fréquenter tous ceux qui sont porteurs
d'idées et ça et il pourra peut être
crédible et être entendu et bien sûr on
s'adosse toujours à un groupe mais c'est
ce travail des lois et ce travail des
lois il faut aller au fond des choses
parce les lois je dis pas que les lois
sont compliqués on va au fond des choses
lorsqu'on est présent ont reproché
essentiellement aux parlementaires de
nos pays abel pas être là-bas à
l'assemblée nationale dans le serai
jusqu à maintenant tout ce que j'ai fait
à travers mes études à travers mon
travail ici je cite j'ai toujours su un
homme d'engagement est donc un homme de
dossiers aussi un homme d'implication
donc si j'y vais ce ils pensent que je
suis disponible pour le faire et je veux
le faire parce que c'est vraiment pour
la martinique il faut être à la hauteur
des enjeux
donc il faut s'impliquer ce que n'a pas
fait le sortant selon vous et bien vous
allez lui poser la question quand il est
question lorsqu il accepterait de venir
chez nous oui ok vous avez posé la
question mais oui mais vous avez comme
le regard de ce qu'il a fait ou pas moi
je pour l'instant dans ce qu'il a fait
je n'ai pas d'éléments je pense que i
loana affirme son bilan et de mon côté
je vois que d'autres ont fait notamment
les habilitations la loi égalité réelle
pas sélectionné l'acceptation
l'acceptation des amendements et les
propositions qui ont été acceptées tout
ça ça c'est du boulot ça c'est du
concret pendant cinq ans mais l'a pour
l'instant là pour moi la feuille blanche
attend vous êtes
du parti progressiste martiniquais david
din al comment voyez-vous par exemple ce
qui se passe dans cette circonscription
du sud avec jean ping lors de coty
silvia neid soutane qui font pourtant
partie de blocs de gestion à l'assemblée
de martinique
eh bien ça permet de voir que au fait ce
qu'on nous avait affronté est un train
peut-être de se diluer d'exploser je ne
sais pas non maintenant attendant mais
toujours est il que la doua dit nous
allons pour gagner et quand vous allez
vous gagnez c'est pour éliminer l'autre
donc on va éliminer on va se régaler
avec sa présence éliminés at rami ils
cherchent à s'éliminer entre amis et les
chances de david inhalent dans tout ça
david inhalent a toutes ses chances
pourquoi parce que par exemple cioni
lors à travailler a été porté par
monsieur marie jeanne à présent vos
idées sont à terre pour nos goûts mais
mais vous met dans le sens de du débat
démocratique de la lutte claire d'assise
à soutenir ni nord pardon marie jeanne
va continuer à soutenir non je ne sais
pas moi je ne sais pas moi je suis pas
devin j'ai pas assez ancien ouais et
votre campagne comment vous la voyez
alors pour concernant la campagne
nous avons mis en place notre
organisation de campagne dans sur tous
les plans dans les communes tout ça et
nous nous attendons aujourd'hui à ce
travail très important d'organisations
de base vous pouvoir mieux travailler
par la suite
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
david inhalons rappelle que vous êtes
candidate ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle dans la circonscription du sud
bonne journée